Emmanuel cost la secrétaire nationale
d'Europe Écologie les vers et l'invité
de preuv par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous à un moment clé pour votre
partie est-il en surci est-ce que Cécile
Dufflot a signé son acte de décès vous
répondrez tout à l'heure aux questions
de Catel prigant de l'Agence France
Presse notre partenaire comme chaque
semaine puis de perinarna de Public
Sénat mais avant cela nous allons parler
d'écologie et oui vous voulez la
promouvoir dites-vous hein mais on
oublie peut-être ces enjeux cruciaux en
raison de la place prise justement par
vos querelles internes mais d'abord
Emmanuel Kos le monde sportif n'est pas
le seul à réagir depuis plusieurs heures
maintenant au dramatique accident
d'hélicoptère en Argentine sur le
tournage d'une nouvelle émission de TF1
10 morts trois légendes du sport
décimé l'émotion est est considérable et
est-ce qu'elle vous a atteint également
bien sûr bah absolument et puis moi je
connaissais pas très bien les sportifs
je dois vous le dire mais mais Florence
sartau c'est quand même une femme très
importante pour notre pays puis pour
beaucoup de femmes ça c'est une réalité
puis elle avait une image de baroudeuse
autonome qui n'avait peur de rien
c'était quand même quelqu'un de très
engagé notamment sur la question de des
mèes enfin comme d'ailleurs beaucoup de
navigateurs et navigatrices donc et puis
ça reste des gens moi j'ai vu les mois
chez des gens plus jeunes que moi qui
m'ont dit tu te rends pas compte la
disparition de Camille MUFA c'est quand
même des des personnes qui ont beaucoup
touché les Français et je pense qu'il
faut voilà faut faut le dire et tout le
monde est évidemment très triste bien
sûr est-ce qu'il faut s'interroger par
ailleurs d'ors et déjà sur le principe
même de ces émissions d'aventure est-ce
qu'elles se sont des productions à trop
haut risque écoutez ça je je je ne sais
pas trop c'est sûr que TF1 là commence à
quand même cumuler euh les histoires
avec des émissions euh où on met les
gens dans des sortes de des émissions de
survie bon après un accident
d'hélicoptère vous savez ça peut aussi
arriver tout simplement quand vous
déplacez donc je pense qu'il faut pas
lier les deux après est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'on pense de la téléréalité on
pourrait avoir une émission d'un heure
sur la culture et qu exprimez votre
opinion là oh je pense qu'il y a de du
très bon et du très mauvais et je crois
que voilà je dis des choses telles que
je pense parce qu'il y a des choses qui
peuvent être intéressantes et compris
qu'il peuvent faire des bat dans notre
société et puis il y a d'autres
émissions qui sont peut-être pas tout à
fait à la
hauteur d'un d' de de la télévision h
alors l'écologie maintenant est-ce que
vous connaissez votre chance en France
vous Emmanuel quelle chance j'ai de la
chance oui par rapport par exemple aux
États-Unis où il y a des parlementaires
là-bas qui disent attaquer le plus grand
des canulars je sais pas si vous avez vu
cette image du président républicain de
la commission du Sénat qui est chargé de
l'environnement Jim inof qui est arrivé
en brandissant une boule de neige pour
contester le réchauffement climatique
alors de ce côté-là si vous me demandez
quelle chance nous avons c'est sûr que
par rapport aux ÉtatsUnis é unis nous
n'avons pas une classe politique qui
remet en cause comme c'est le cas aux
États-Unis aujourd'hui la la la question
les faits les constats sur le
réchauffement
climatique si on regarde ce qui s'est
passé depuis 2009 avec la conférence de
copenhag où il y avait eu tout un débat
sur les analyses donc du GC du
groupement international qui travaille
là-dessus je pense qu'on a fait un bon
en avant très intéressant qui est
qu'aujourd'hui à part peut-être
quelques-uns personne ne remet en cause
des dérèglements climaqu
donc ça c'est en effet une chance c'est
aussi une chance parce qu'aux États-Unis
vous avez une classe politique qui est
en fait très libertarienne et très
libertaire et qui ne veut surtout pas
discuter ça mais qui est aussi très en
en cheville avec des lobbyes économiques
qui ne veulent surtout pas qu'on
discutentv les employés de l'État de
Floride n'ont même pas le droit
d'utiliser l'expression réchauffement
climatique hein oui mais il y a il y a
ça et puis il y a aussi le poids des
grands groupes pétroliers qui ne veulent
pas discuter de leur manière dont ils
extraient le pétrole vous avez vu tout
le débat qu'il y a aujourd'hui avec une
un conflit fort entre Barack Obama et
les républi les républiains sur
l'histoire de ce qui pourrait se passer
sur l'extraction de pétrole donc c'est
un débat très important mais la réalité
et c'est pour ça que le le dernier
rapport du GC qui ENF qui pas un rapport
mais les analyses du GC qui ont été
faites en vue de la conférence
climatique à Paris dans quelques mois
dit des choses très clairement le
dérèglement climatique et réchauffement
climatique évidemment déjà là la
question est de savoir si on peut
limiter ce réchauff à 2 degrés et déjà
si on fait ça nous ne pourrons pas faire
face à l'ensemble des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique mais c'est on
estime qu'en limitant à 2 degrés déjà
nous serons peut-être maîtriser les
choses on limite les catastrophes on
limite les catastrophes il y en aura
quand même et c'est pour ça ça qu'il
faut absolument se mobiliser aujourd'hui
les catastrophes elles sont là en Chine
par exemple on va voyager un peu en
Chine il y a un documentaire qui
embarrasse le pouvoir depuis quelques
semaines d'ailleurs le pouvoir l'a
interdit mais il y a eu des millions de
vues sur Internet vous avez vu c'est le
film d'une ancien journaliste d'ailleurs
de la télévision d'État sous le dos mais
une enquête donc terrible sur la
pollution des villes chinoises sur les
ravages sur la santé sur l'impuissance
publique également or le charbon fournit
les 2 tiers de l'énergie en Chine on se
demande si le nucléaire ne permettrait
pas de vivre plus sainement en Chine
alors la Chine se pose d'ailleurs la
question en se disant parce que la Chine
est très consciente quel quoi qu'on
pense de cet État qui n'est pas
démocratique et qui je le rappelle
notamment juste avant les Jeux
Olympiques de Pékin a emprisonné
énormément de militants de la cause
environnementale et qui avait notamment
dénoncé déjà en 2007 2008 ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui dans ce reportage et
la question savoir c'est ce pays qui se
développe considérablement comment
peut-il faire faire à la pollution de l'
alors il y a la question du charbon il y
a aussi un autre sujet pour la Chine qui
est le trafic automobile parce que le
niveau de vie aussi dénoncer dans le
documentauile augmentant fortement les
Chinois ont acquis des véhicules
automobiles très polluants et
aujourd'hui hi vivre dans une ville
c'est c'est c'est ces mégapoles
chinoises absolument terrible il y a une
pollution de l'eau absolument aussi
terrifiantes et des problèmes sur la
santé très fort la Chine l'a très bien
compris parce qu'aujourd'hui les
questions environnementales sont en
train d'être un obstacle à son
développement économique et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a vu que la Chine a été
voir les États-Unis a voulu négocier un
accord en AM oui on peut faire confiance
à la Chine pour vous par exemple manuel
Val s'est rendu récemment en Chine en
disant que qu' son appui serait
déterminant et sera déterminant lors de
la fameuse conférence de la fin vous
savez pour la conférence climatique on
va besoin de tout le monde ça veut pas
dire que chaque état va faire le chemin
nécessaire et va aller là où il doit
aller mais on a besoin qu'ils avancent
tous on a vu une évolution qui à mon
avis n'est pas suffisante mais qui est
quand même indéniable le fait que les
États-Unis et la Chine a signé un accord
pour ensemble décider de baisser leur
émission de gaz à effet de serre et donc
d'avoir une action sur la développement
économique est très importante après il
y a pas que que fera l'Australie qui a
aussi aujourdui our'hi beaucoup à revoir
de son comportement que fera la Russie
et la Russie nous le savons aujourd'hui
dans la crise politique dans laquelle
nous sommes la la Russie peut aussi
vouloir marchander son sa position sur
la question climatique pour d'autres
raisons mais ce que tous ces états
savent aujourd'hui et il compris la
Chine qui pendant longtemps a fait
n'importe quoi avec les questions
verbales et continue d'ailleurs à
saccager l'environnement dans ce pays
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont la Chine a aussi compris qu'il y a
pas de Planète B c'est ce que à dit Bank
Kimon il y a plusieurs plusieurs mois je
nous le répète nous sommes tous à le
répé et une fois qu'on aura tout détruit
ce qui a sous nos pied on pourra pas
faire autre chose est-ce que vous êtes
confiante sur la signature d'un accord à
la fin de l'année en tout cas il faut y
croire l de cette conférence sur
laquelle François Hollande mise beaucoup
mais tout le monde doit miser je vous
êtes confiante je ne sais je veux y
croire je dirais pas que je suis
confiante parce que c'est c'est quand
même mais non mais c'est un accord avec
160 chefs d'État on est dans une phase
diplomatique très complee et on est
Chaudé par les précédentes conféren
exactement mais en même temps si nous y
arrivions ça sera un impact planétaire
extrêmement important et la réalité
c'est qu'on ne peut plus voiler la face
donc le fait que c'est lieu en France
qu'on a un chef d'État engagé que la
population française commence à se
mobiliser fortement dans des tas de
manifestations localement c'est
extrêmement important tout ça justifie
votre soutien donc au chef de l'État sur
cette question oui mais pas simplement
mon soutien je pense au soutien de
l'ensemble des personnes qui pensent
qu'il faut faire mieux pour la planète
d'accord mais là je parlait de la
responsable d'Europe Écologie Les vert à
qui j'aimerais montrer une autre image
tiens l'image de l'avion solaire solaire
impulse 2 qui a été lancé qui est lancé
là dans son tour du monde historique
pour changer le monde hein disent ses
promoteurs donc mettre en avant
l'énergie propre ça vous rend
enthousiaste ah oui enfin déjà ça fait
rêver faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont puis ça me rend
enthousiaste parce que aujourd'hui nous
savons qu'on ne pourra plus envisager le
monde avec des consommations d'énergie
très fortes parce que d'une part les
énergies fossiles à un moment elles vont
elles ne vont plus être présentes et en
plus on peut pas continuer à polluer
n'importe enfin comme espoir c'est c'est
là il est ce sont pas les politiques qui
le font lever là Emmanuel ce sont les
chercheurs les stifiques il faut leur
faire confiance mais l'espoir c'est
c'est tout le monde notamment sur
l'innovation l'innovation vous savez
elle est aussi au cœur des progrès
environnementaux si aujourd'hui on a une
telle montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables c'est aussi parce qu'on
sait mieux capter le le soleil on sait
mieux capter l'air on sait mieux faire
de l'hydraulique on arrive à avoir des
ingénieurs qui nous inventent des
nouveaux systèmes les éoliennes sont
plus rentables aujourd'hui qu'elle
l'était il y a 10 ans et c'est pareil
pour les panneaux photovolta fa faire
confiance aux chercheurs parfois ils ont
l'impression de trouver de
l'obscurantisme en facee 2 vous savez
hein chez les contestataires non je
pense
que je sais très bien que vous alleiez
parler des OGM non mais sans parler de
cel non mais moi vous savez je je
n'oppose pas l'innovation et le progrès
et l'avenir et les écologistes sont pour
le progrès l'avenir simplement ce qu'ils
disent c'est que ce qu'on doit créer ce
qu'on doit chercher on doit savoir quels
sont quel est son impact sur le futur et
on on doit savoir ce que ça crée dans
notamment la biodiversité aujourd'hui le
fait que nous ayons mis des OGM dans les
cultures objectivement quels sont les
dommages que ça crée dans les cultures
avoisinantes discutez avec des
agriculteurs comme je l'ai fait au salon
de l'agriculture qui vous disent que eux
ils ne mettent pas d'OGM ils sont en bio
ils sont contaminés par les champs aux
alentours de même qu'ils ne mettent pas
de pesticides et qu's sont contaminés et
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus d'abeilles
dans leur champ donc il faut aussi se
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont à
force de vouloir au nom de l'innovation
imposer ces progrès qui n'en sont
peut-être pas on a aussi complètement
déréglé le système agricole et la
biodiversité et c'est important puisque
vous le savez la loi sur la biodiversité
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale la
semaine prochaine alors il y a aussi un
autre texte qui fait débat c'est la loi
de Solen royale sur la transition
énergétique et le Parlement cherche une
synthèse apparemment la ministre et
vous-même devrez attendre puisque une
nouvelle lecture he puisque il n'y a pas
de compromis entre les députés et les
sénateurs ces derniers refusent
l'échéance de 2025 pour la réduction
à 50 % de la part du nucléaire vous
estimez qu'on perd trop de temps ah non
je pense qu'on a perdu et beaucoup de
temps au Sénat qui a complètement
détricoé le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale à la sortie du Sénat le texte
sur la transition énergétique a remis en
cause les engagement du Président de la
République sur la réduction de la part
du nucléaire dans la production
électrique le texte de loi a
complètement transformé ce qui était
prévu pour le développement des des
énergies éoliennes alors que c'est un
atout majeur qu'il faut qu'on développe
dans notre pays et il a en plus enlevé
un grand nombre de dispositions
notamment sur les plans de mobilité dans
les entreprises qui essaient de faire
évoluer les pratiques dans notre pays
donc il y a un momentut PR mais
évidemment et donc on va perdre du temps
alors ben on va perdre du temps j'aurais
voulu que le sén le Sénat soit sage mais
que voulez-vous il n'a pas voulu écouter
euh ce qui avait été fait à l'Assemblée
nationale avec un texte qui était le
fruit d'un compromis très important un
travail de très longue haleine c'est ça
la démocratie euh donc la CMP la
commission mix par TER a certainement
échoué et on repartira vers un nouvel
examen de loi d'accord euh est-ce que
vous êtes aujourd'hui convaincu que
Fessenheim fermera en 2017 ouiou je suis
convaincu le président de la République
l'a encore redit il y a maintenant une
semaine exactement et je le redis je
pense que maintenant l'année 2015 il
faut que les actes soient pris au sein
du conseil d'administration de DF pour
que fessenim ferme dans les temps
impartis par le Président de la
République il vous l'a dit directement
aussi peut-être non oui enfin on s' vous
savez est un peu le sujet récurrent de
nos discussions d'AC et d'autres comme
d'autresjets sur lesquels on va venir
dans un instant mais encore une question
sur SIG Royal elle a évoqué la piste
d'un référendum sur l'avenir de
l'aéroport de notred-dame des land
est-ce que ce serait une solution pour
vous alors elle a elle a dit que ça
serait un moyen d'exprimer d'exprimer
une un avis sur la question je vais vous
dire la réalité c'est que si on
demandait dans la région s fa faire
référendum je n'ai je suis pas très
inquiète du résultat de ce référendum
non dans une région où les dans une
régionoui vous savez c'est pas les élus
qui répondent au référendum c'est la
population et je peux vous le dire pour
avoir été à plusieurs reprises à
notred-dame d'é land que j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de gens locaux de population
locale qui depuis très longtemps se
battent contre certain rortement vous
soutenez cette idée de référendum alors
laissez-moi terminer ce que je dis c'est
que je n'ai pas du tout peur de l'issue
de cette de ce référendum simplement
pourquoi faire un référendum aujourd'hui
quand la Commission européenne a pointé
les infraction à différentes directives
européennes quand il y a de nombreux
recours juridiques notamment sur la
protection d'espèces protégées sur la
question des zones humides et tout ça je
veux dire par là que aujourd'hui
arrivent des arguments juridiques très
forts sur l'illégalité de ce projet et
je pense qu'on a pas besoin d'un
référendum pour dire qu'il faut
l'abandonner très bien voilà votre
position alors on va parler de votre
parti donc maintenant super avec Catel
prigant de l'Agence France Presse donc
une cission est clairement évoquée
désormais après les derniers propos de
Cécile du flot qui penche toujours plus
à gauche et donc on a hâte d'avoir votre
avis mais d'abord présentation un petit
peu des différents camps qui se font
face et de ce fossé qui se creuse avec
Louis
sibyil le parti antinucléaire menacé de
fission atomique il y a ceux au pied du
perron de l'Élysée qui ne cachent pas
leur désir de récupérer un ministère et
puis il y a ceux qui ne veulent pas ou
ne veulent plus en faire partie entre
quelques parlementaires et les cadres du
parti écologiste la guerre est déclarée
Cécile Duflot va jusqu'à imaginer
l'explosion d'Europe Écologie Les ver il
faut rassembler tous ceux qui veulent
changer de modèle si nous avons du
courage quelque chose va bouger une
nouvelle force politique va
émerger réaction immédiate du patron des
veres à l'Assemblée nationale elle dit
en quelque sorte il va falloir faire une
nouvelle force politique bon elle signe
un peu l'acte de décès d'Europe Écologie
Les ver ce qui est un peu surprenant
d'ailleurs le sénateur Jean-Vincent plac
travaille beaucoup en coulisse pour un
retour au gouvernement temporise le
choix des alliances le choix des
stratégies ça fait partie de la vie
démocratique d'un parti politique
personne ne cherche à assiciner oui la
question c'est est-ce qu'il faut des
écologistes au gouvernement tout comme
des centristes tout comme l'ensemble des
socialistes oui c'est les choses sont
claires signe d'une potentielle sission
le sénateur a reçu aujourd'hui Jean-Luc
benamias cet ancien cadre des veres
pronne une nouvelle fédération
d'écologistes sous l'gide de l'Élysée il
faudra bien que tous ces gens-là se
regroupent je parle de ceux qui sont en
politique positive en politique qui
pensent que il est bon de gouverner il
est bon de participer aux réalisations
de transformation des politiques
publiques pour contrecarer toute
initiative personnelle le parti a pris
les devants interdiction de revenir au
gouvernement sans l'accord du Conseil
fédéral sous peine d'être exclus
l'ex-ministre Pascal campfin a encore un
pied à l'Élysée il s'occupe de la
conférence climat à la fin de l'année il
reste prudent aujourd'hui au sein
d'Europe Écologie les vers il y a entre
70 et 80 20 % des adhérents et des
cadres du mouvement qui sont
défavorables en l'état sur la base de la
politique actuelle à un retour au
gouvernement après la dépacle annoncé
des départementales tout un petit monde
s'agite pour préparer un potentiel
remanimement l'Élysée pencherait pour
une cission des vers et la création d'un
nouveau parti compatible avec l'exécutif
voilà Catel Prigent de la FP est avec
nous bonsoir Catel V question donc sur
ce
débat divise les vers est-ce que Cécile
Dufflot a signé un acte de décès
d'Europe Écologie les vers comme le dit
François ROG non comme d'autres n'ont
pas signé un acte d'ouverture de quoi
que ce soit moi je pense qu'il va
falloir que tout le monde respire un bon
coup et et se calme un peu dans la
période au moins je vais vous dire on a
toujours dit dans notre partie les gens
s'exprimaiit qu'il y avait une
biodiversité qu'on était dans une
capacité à à gérer les points de vues
différents il y a il a un débat dans le
parti et il est très présent est-ce
qu'on doit aller dans un gouvernement et
si on y va c'est pourquoi faire avec
quelle marche de manœuvre comment
défendre au mieux les questions de
l'écologie et c'est ça qui doit nous
animer et moi c'est ce que je redis tout
le temps c'est l'écologie l'écologie
l'écologie non mais je le dis très de
manière très importante parce qu'après
la question de savoir le parti la siss
un autre parti ceci cela vous savez quoi
les écologistes vont pas attendre que
quelqu'un décide pour eux donc un moment
ils ont fait un choix en avril 2014 et
il s'ils en font un autre si on nous
propose quelque chose parce que faut
aussi dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont chacun s'amuse aujourd'hui à faire
de la politique fiction moi je regarde
le moment le moment c'est les élections
départementales et nous verrons bien ce
qui va se passer dans les semaines qui
viennentil y a un débat dans le parti on
a plutôt l'impression qu'il y a plus de
débat il y a quand même Cécile Duflot
d'un côté
jeanvinçin on voit que ça réagit tout de
suite dès que l'un parle l'autre
derrière Cécile dufl Jeanin placé et
moi-même il y a des adhérents qui
débattent et qui n'attendent pas que
nous discutions les uns les autres sur
notre notre de notre position qui
débattent entre eux et qui continueront
à débattre ce qui est certain c'est que
dans notre parti et ça date même d'avant
2012 il y a eu des débats sur savoir
est-ce que notre parti doit faire partie
d'une majorité avec François Hollande
est-ce qu'on doit soutenir les
socialistes dans leur accession au
pouvoir et qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire et
donc c'est un débat important pour les
écologistes de savoir comment on pèse et
je le redit non mais quelle est votre
position vous parce que là ma position
elle est très simple les écologistes et
je l'ai dit il n a aucun un tabou sur
ces questions là si on doit aller au
gouvernement il faut y aller pour de
bonnes raisons on y va pas pour sauver
un tel vous n'excluez pas contrairement
àour déjà c'est un point de divergence
je ne dis ni il ne faut pas y aller ni
il faut y aller à tout prix je dis il
faut faire de l'écologie et quand les
écologieses sont responsable et qui
peuvent faire de l'écologie ils le font
question et la question est de savoir
est-ce que nous aurons l'occasion de le
faire est-ce que nous aurons les marges
de manvre qu sont justement les marges
de manœuvre que vous demandez
éventuellement si jamais on vous propose
alors la question et c'est pas à vous
que je le diraiis parce que j'espère
avoir des discussions avec d'autres
personnes que des journalistes pour
discuter de ces
conditionsl not aussi avec les membres
de mon parti mais la question c'est de
porter des politiques écolo Comment
faire mes faim comment faire que la
transition énergétique soit au cœur des
politiques public comment faire qu'on
développe on parle de développement
économique allons sur la question des
filières vertes et tous ces sujetsl
est-ce que on change les institutions et
on crée la proportionnelle je dis pas
que ce sont des conditions je dis que ce
sont des sujets que nous avons F vousê
en train de nous
les points d'un nouau tout cas ce que
j'explique c'est que c'est des points
sur lesquels nous tournons autour depuis
2011 même avant la présidentielle et sur
lesquells il faut absolument qu'on
avance dans ce pays on parle beaucoup de
2017 on parle beaucoup du risque du
Front national de l'inquiétude pour la
gauche si on veut que la gauche soit
victorieuse et donc la gauche c'est
aussi les écologistes il faut faire des
politiques qui parlent à la gauche et
aux écologistes et donc il faut faire de
l'écologie ce sont des points que vous
aviez déjà abordés à votre entrée au
gouvernement vous êtes sorti du
gouvernement parce que c'est ces points
n'avaient pas été résolus est-ce que si
on vous en reparle vous attendez des
actes avant de dire oui ou vous repartez
des on attend des actes des marches de
manœuvre après la politique n'est pas
faite que de paroes et on attend aussi
un chemin non mais c'est quoi je je
disais un contrat de gouvernement et un
chemin un contrat de gouvernement un
contrat de gouvernement ou autre chose
mais aussi un chemin si vraiment les
élections départemental qui Arve dans 15
jours signe des choses très difficiles
pour la gauche et pour les écologistes
et pour le camp des progressistes en
général apparment ce sera le cas hein on
parle d'unoute c'est si c'est le cas il
faut aussi avoir que une capacité à dire
quelque chose que va dire le
gouvernement au lendemain de ses
élections par rapport aux 2 années et
demi qui lui reste à gouverner donc
quand je parle de chemin c'est
essentiel chque c'est essentiel pour
estce que Manuel vas doit
démissionner vous savez j'ai jamais
voulu répondre à ces question là parce
que je ne suis pas présidente de la
République et je pense que les
politiques qui ont toujours un avis sur
quel quel ministre doit démissionner ou
doit partir ça pourrait vous aider
puisque mais c'est pas ça le sujet vous
savez quoi on fait pas de la politique
tour au gouvernement à cause de manuel
c'est ce qu' expliqué Cécile Duflot moi
je peux vous dire que le parti n'est pas
rentre gouvernement en 2014 parce qu'il
estimait que les conditions n'étaient
pas réunies et c'est pour ça que il y a
une large majorité sur le la question à
l'époque il y aura un meeting commun
important lundi soir avec Manuel Vals
vous participez oui le lendemain vous
êtes à un meeting avec Pierre Laurent
absolument il y aura une différence de
discours entre lundi soir et M
absolument pas et je vais vous dire moi
je suis très à l'aise je vais au meeting
en pour en soutien de Jérôme Gede en
esson un frondeur un frondeur et aussi
aussi un ami qui est à la tête d'un
département qui fait des politiques très
audacieuse notamment sur la question de
l'inégalité des territoires et de la et
de d'essayer de remettre dans un
département qui est très urbain et très
rural vraiment une réconciliation de ces
territoire moi en plus en tant qu'élu
local régional vous le savez j'ai
beaucoup ra ces politiques et je n'ai
aucun problème avec ça nous avonsê le
meeting de la grande sur un air de
réconciliation mais c'est pas le sujet
les écologistes en Nesson ont fait le
choix d'accompagner la majorité sortante
et donc celle de Jérôme GED nous avons
fait le choix dans d'autres départements
d'accompagner également la majorité
sortante et y compris d'accompagner des
élus communistes ou des élus Front de
Gauche sortant donc je vais vous dire
quelque chose à partir du moment où nous
n'avons pas réussi et c'est un problème
je pense pour l'ensemble des partis de
la gauche et pour les écologistes on n'
pas réussi à faire dans ces binômes qui
sont en fait ils sont ils sont quatre
avec les suppléants à réunir tout le
monde il fallait aussi assumer que nous
ayons euh des alliances avec le Parti
socialiste avec le Front de gauche et
pour tout vous dire le Parti socialiste
même s'il ne le dit pas il a aussi des
alliances très mélangées et très
bigarées sur le terrain puisque je
n'arrête pas de me déplacer que je vois
aussi que eux-mêmes n'ont pas non plus
des stratégies totalement monolitiiques
ils ont même parfois des soutiens au
candidats de l'UDI ou du MoDem donc je
pense qu'on peut quand même aussi se
dire que dans cette élection très
particulière il y a en effet des des
choix locaux qui ont été différents vous
savez quand même bien que l'image de
vous à côté d'Emmanuel Vals va faire à
peu près autant parler que celle de
Cécile du flou à côté de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon oui sauf que vous savez moi je
fais pas de la politique avec des états
d'âes je vais soutenir manuel Jérôme
Gedge manuel Val c'est formidable mais
non mais je suis pas là pour Manuel Vals
après c'est son département je savais
très bien que en esson il viendrait un
jour de même que si je vais en scène
saintis je vais rencontrer Claude
Bartolone et que si j'allais dans le
Nord je rencontrerai d'autres figures
donc il faut les choses telles qu'elles
sont on connaît quand même la réalité de
ce pays et en même temps je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que l'ensemble
des électeurs de gauche réfléchissent à
ce qui va se passer dans 15 jours est-ce
que vraiment ils veulent que des
départements changent de bord politique
et donc changent de politique est-ce
qu'ils veulent vraiment que les
politiques de solidarité ne soient plus
les mêmes est-ce qu'il veulent vraiment
que des élus d'extrême droite qui ont
imp parti des des propositions qui font
des triis entre les populations prennent
du poids dans ces institutions et on
verra les conséquences que ça peut avoir
dans les politiqu de solidarité c'est ça
la question qui se pose et moi je le dis
très franchement à tout le monde ce
n'est pas du tout l'histoire de de faire
perdre faire peur sur le front nationale
c'est est-ce que un moment on peut
regarder réellement quelle est la
politique du département dans lequel on
vit est-ce qu'on souhaite que cette
politique soit menée différemment
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit poursuivie ou
que il y ait une plus grande pluralité
de représentants mais il faut vraiment
se réfléchir à cette question et ne pas
se dire que la question est nationale
parce que ce n'est pas vrai d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de Manuel
Vals lundi soir donc dans les sones
puisque vous avez reproché euh son
sentimentalisme lorsqu'il parle du Front
national vous lui demandez surtout
change de sujet mais je lui demande rien
et je pense que il fait aura le discours
qu'il veut comme je ferai le mien ce que
je lui demande c'est d'être comme moi en
soutien derrière l'ensemble des candid
essayer de ne pas être en contradiction
hein quand même hein vous savez moi je
vais aller défendre mon engagement
auprès de Jérôme Gede ce que nous avons
voulu faire dans ce département et aussi
de combattre le Front National et en
effet je pense qu'on combat le Front
national en dénonçant son programme ses
propositions et ses pratiques et ce qui
s'est passé hier au Parlement européen
illustre bien aussi comment dans ce
parti on on utilise le système pour se
remplir bien les postes et ne surtout
pas faire le travail ouverte par le
Parlement européen sur le rôle des
assistants parlementaires par Pay par
l'Europe mais qui ne travaillent pas
pour l'un EUR mais je peux vous dire
nous nos parlements parlementaires
européens et leurs collaborateurs ils le
voient très bien tous les jours
justement que répondez-vous à ceux qui
disent que la division de la gauche
favorise aussi la montée du FN dans les
départementales que je remarque ce qui
favorise le FN là aujourd'hui c'est
l'instauration d'un scrutin ultra
majoritaire parce qu'on m'a longtemps
dit la proportionnelle vous êtes fous en
développant la proportionnelle vous
faites monter le Front national là on a
un scrutin majoritaire où une condition
a été posée qui est extrêmement dure qui
est pour que se maintenir au second tour
il faut avoir fait 12 % et demi des
inscrits ce qui est un score très élevé
et je remarque que c'est comme ça qu'en
fait beaucoup dans beaucoup d'endroits
il n'y aura que deux candidatures au
second tour et notamment le le Front
national c'est pas la division vous
savez qui amène le Front national c'est
le fait que les gens ne comprennent plus
soient désespérés et ne comprennent plus
quelle est la force de la parole
politique et c'est pour ça qu'il y a ce
vote là aussi il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont si depuis 2 ans et
demi François Hollande et ses premiers
ministres successifs avaient
véritablement repris ce qu'ils avaient
annoncé dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle je pense que la distance
entre ces électeurs et le gouvernement
sera évidemment différente aujourd'hui
et c'est aussi ça qui dit qu'à un moment
des gens par dépit pas simplement par
adhésion mais souvent par dépit se
disent pourquoi ne pas aller vers le
Front National et puis après je pense
quetion que leur dites-vous justement à
ces gens qui maintenant se disent
pourquoi ne pas aller vers le Front
national estce que vous reprenez le
discours de l'exécutif et des
responsables socialistes Jean-Christophe
cambadis qui disent tous regardez la
situation s'améliore non moi ce que je
dis regardez pour qui vous votez et
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire avec ces
gens-là regardez ce que propose le Front
national par exemple sur les prestations
envers les personnes âgées sur les
person personnes handicapées sur la
petite enfance l'ensemble des
prestations sociales qui aujourd'hui
sont au cœur des politiques ne dit pas
qu'ils vont les supprimer hein non mais
ils disent très clairement si vous
n'êtes pas français ceci cela vous ne
l'aurez plus et puis on va faire vous
savez le maire du ponté là qui a été
invalidé une des premières mesure qu'il
a prise dans sa commune c'est de
supprimer l'accès au cantines des
enfants de chômeurs on parle du parti
qui est soit-disant près du peuple près
des pauvres et près de leur difficulté
et la première chose qu'il a fait c'est
de dire les enfants de chômeurs n'ont
pas le droit de rentrer à la cantine
est-ce que vous imaginez ce que ça veut
dire pour ces familles qui souvent de
fait ont une difficulté justement pour
que leurs enfants se sentent dans une
vie normale comme les autres et en fait
ils sont encore plus exclus et moi je le
dis le Front national c'est un parti qui
pratique l'exclusion qui ne fait pas qui
ne répond rien aux difficultés
quotidiennes des Français et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut qu'àun moment notre peuple
les Français réagissent se réveillent
ils ont le droit de contester moi-même
je ne suis pas du tout en accord avec
beaucoup de choses qui sont faites dans
ce pays il n'empêche que je regarde
aussi à quoi sert mon vote et qu'est-ce
que je veux pour moi-même dans les
semaines qui viennent bon ben dans les
semaines qui viennent j'ai encore une
question un peu politicienne excusez-moi
Emmanuel quelle chance vous vous donnez
d'avoir des ministres écolos début avril
ah moi je réfléchis vraiment pas comme
ça alors là
vous vous me prenez vraiment chance vous
êes en train de négocier un contrat on
c'est pas une question de chance la
question c'est vous savez au lendemain
des municipales moi j'avais dit dans les
dans les les différentes différents
plateaux au lendemain des des élections
plus d'écologie plus de sociale un
retour un fort lien a siété et nous
verrons au au soir des élections ce qui
se passe nous verrons aussi ce que le
président de la République veut faire
estce que comme Jean placé vous vous
soulignez son volontarisme maintenant
sur la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique oui mais ça c'est pas lié aux
écologistes excusez-moi Catel encore
heureux et c'est vraiment essentiel que
président de la République est décidé de
faire de la conférence climat et donc
des mois qui nous rapprochent de la
conférence climat une mobilisation très
forte là-dessus et ça rien à voir avec
l'histoire des écologistes c'est une
question planétaire la question c'est
est-ce que la la France va être capable
d'amener des chefs d'État et enfin enfin
je dis bien parce que ça fait quand même
unant plus de 5 ans et voir plus
longtemps qu'on essaie d'avoir un accord
contraignant est-ce qu'on est capable
d'avoir une politique mondiale qui soit
digne de ce nom encore une question de
chance C sera la dernière la dernière
vous êtes parieur en fait un peu quelle
chance vous donnez à la formation à la
nouvelle formation politique est-ce qui
s par Cécile duf de voir le jour ah bah
ce que dit Cécile c'est suffisamment
aujourd'hui général pour pour que ça
soit extrêmement difficile de prendre
les paris ce qui est certain ça soit ce
que annonce Cécile Duflot sur le fait
qu'il faut trouver un mouvement qui
reprenne lien avec la société ou ce que
dit là Jean-Luc benamia sur la question
des écologistes il est certain que le
camp des écologistes aujourd'hui doit se
ressouder ça c'est une réalité moi ça
fait longtemps que j'en appelle de mes
vœux on a réussi à le faire en 2009 avec
Danon Bendit et c'est vrai qu'ensuite
nous avons reperdu un peu ce champl
notamment après la primaire interne que
nous avons eu sur la présidentielle et
ça il faudra de tout toute manière que
nous arrivions à trouver un lieu où la
société française soit réconciliée avec
les les militants écologistes merci
Catel perine Tarna arrive maintenant et
on va vous suivre sur le terrain
électoral Samia dechir vous a
effectivement accompagné en
campagne merci macueillir ambiance
décontractée chez les vers tout le monde
se tutoie se fait la bise nous sommes
dans le département du rô Emmanuel K est
venu soutenir des candidats au
département
au programme visite d'un village équipé
d'une centrale solaire en dehors des
militants les habitants ne la
connaissent pas il faut dire que la
patronne des écolos ne cour pas les
plateaux télé on peut pas construire les
choses en politique uniquement sur
quelque chose de médiatique ça se fait
aussi parce qu'à moment on essaie de
persuader des gens qu'on fait de la
pédagogie et qu'on a des actions je dis
ça parce qu'il y a des gens en politique
qui sont très connus qui sont des objets
médiatiques et qu' on pas fait
grandchose non plus de leur vie ancienne
présidente d'ct puis journaliste elle a
rejoint les ver en 2009 4 ans plus tard
elle devient secrétaire nationale un
poste d'équilibriste dans un parti où
les ténor n'hésite pas à étaler leur
division sur l'éventualité d'un retour
au gouvernement j'essaie de dire à tout
le monde de respecter les un et les
autres je dis notamment aux dirigeants
et je le dis aussi aux militants des
militants déboussolés qu'il a fallu
rassurer en maintenant l'unité du parti
on est dans une organisation ultra
compliquée
avec panel de prise de position de choix
politique et autrre que pour arriver à à
avoir une posture un peu près équilibrée
faut le faire elle rappelle que c'est le
mouvement c'est le parti le Conseil
fédéral enfin ces instances qui doivent
définir la politique du parti et non des
personnalités isolées qui ont leur
intéresse c'est une chose qu'elle elle a
essayé de redonner la parole au parti le
soir face aux militants de véeux il est
question de précarité énergétique et de
logement et c'est là sur les dossiers de
fond qu'on la sent la plus à l'aise la
politique institutionnelle oui je
pourrais la quitter un jour moi je veux
agir je j'ai c'est pour ça que j'ai
milité c'est pour ça que je milite et
dans l'ensemble de ma vie j'ai voulu
être active et tout ça et euh j'assume
parfaitement ma responsabilité qui est
la mienne aujourd'hui mais moi dans 10
ans peut-être que je serai à la tête
d'une association sur tel ou tel sujet
et pour moi c'est pas antinomique mais
elle n'écarte pas non plus l'idée d'un
avenir ministériel François Hollande
diton aimerait la faire entrer au
gouvernement
voilà est avec nous alors on s'interroge
évidemment sur tout ce qui se dit dans
le secret du bureau du chef de l'État
ENF quand même quand on voit ce
reportage on a envie de se dire que chef
de parti c'est quand même un salale
métier oui oui vous
confirmezcologie les ver
particulièrement non demander à
Jean-Cristophe cambadellis à Pierre
Laurent ou même à Nicolas sarzy je pense
que c'est c'est une fonction qui est
très particulière et puis je vais vous
dire hein on parle des divisions
soit-disant des veres je regarde ce qui
se passe notamment à l'UMP actuellement
ou chez les centristes excusez-moi ou
chez les socialistes nous moi j'ai juste
l'impression que nous nous avons la
gentillesse de laisser les portes
ouvertes et donc de les exposer un peu
plus mais je pense que c'est quand même
quand même on a l'impression en ce
moment que vous faites un peu un grand
écart permanent en allant par exemple
sur le terrain soutenir des candidats
qui peuvent être proche du Parti
socialiste ou d'autres qui au
contraire sont en campagne avec le fond
élection local avec des situations
locales très différentes et où les
stratégies électorales ont été décidées
au niveau départemental donc à partir de
là je peux vous dire les écologistes
notamment j'étais dans un département
dans le gare la semaine dernière nous
soutenons tous les sortants de la
majorité du département donc il y a des
socialistes il y a des communistes et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est pas tous
ensemble sur le même canton parce que
ces deux partis n'ont pas voulu se
parler qu'est-ce que vous voulezass
quand même sur terrain vous pouvez vous
retrouver dans des positions un peu SK
tout pas du tout soutenir les
écologistes amener plus d'écologie dans
majorité et défendre aussi la
participation citoyenne parce que
typiquement dans le déplacement que j'ai
fait hier on soutient une liste ou sur
quatre personnes trois sont des citoyens
qui ne sont pas encartés et qui font
aussi le choix d'aller s'engager tribun
on fustige la politique du gouvernement
et sur
d'autres on la célèbre compris avec le
Premier ministre dans les sones c'est
compliqué mais le sujet c'est que à
partir du moment où vous avez des
élections de la sorte ce était pas
compliqué pour notre part c'est soit de
mettre aucun candidat comme ça on s
merdez pas soit de dire juste des
écologistes tout seul partout sauf que
vous le savez très bien aujourd'hui ce
sont des élections où pour la première
fois on présente des binômes et en fait
c'est quatre personnes sur des cantons
et il y a un moment ça pousse aussi à
faire des accords y compris locaux et
moi je ne vois pas où est le problème
que localement on puisse avoir des
stratégies différentes la question est
de savoir pourquoi faire pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça si c'est juste pour avoir
un petit supplément d'AM des uns et des
autres ça n'a aucun intérêt si c'est
pour bouger la politique des département
là ça a un intérêt visibilité locale ok
mais est-ce qu'il y a une lisibilité
pour l'ensemble des citoyens au niveau
national estce qu'il y a une lisibilité
pour l'ensemble citoyens de ces
élections les écologistes ont fait le
choix de nêtre présent que dans la
moitié des cantons du pays il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont dans la
dans beaucoup de cantons o est-ce que
c'est un choix ou c'est par défaut non
c'est pas c'est un choix parfois par
défaut dans certains départementsù nos
implantations sont faibles mais
essentiellement par choix et notamment
en raison du Front national notamment
vous voyez encore tout à l'heure je
m'interrogeais sur un département et
j'ai vu que nous avons avons décidé de
ne mettre aucun candidat face à tel
sortant socialiste qui est en difficulté
face à tel sortant divers gauche qui est
en difficulté donc c'est aussi des choix
que nous avons fait intelligent et à
chaque fois c'est de se dire comment
est-ce qu'on porte l'écologie après il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont nous c'est des élections sur
lesquelles nous avons très peu de
sortants parce que jusque-là ces parties
majoritaires dont nous parlons avaient
très peu envie de faire de la place à
leurs partenaires et c'est d'ailleurs un
des problèmes de ces conseils généraux
qui au-delà de leur manque de parité
réelle était aussi très peu divers en
terme de représentation politique donc
la situation on en est là aujourd'hui
parce que elle elle elle elle elle elle
vient en fait aussi d'une histoire
politique locale très forte euh pour
revenir au reportage qu'on qu'on vient
de voir à l'instant on a envie de savoir
à qui vous pensez quand vous évoquez des
objets médiatiques qui sont ces objets
médiatiques non mais euh la la est-ce
que c'est un portrait en creux par
exemple de Cécile duffl qui est une bête
médiatique c'est pas péjoratif hein
quand je ah non non mais par ailleurs
Cécile Duflot a énormément de talent et
euh si l'écologie on est là aujourd'hui
c'est notamment grâce à elle et je pense
que euh tout le monde devrait s'en
souvenir et notamment dans cette période
non je disais simplement parce que la
question qui m'était posée c'était le
point médiatique ça fait un an que je
suis chef de parti il est normal que je
n'ai pas le point médiatique de
personnes qui sont investies depuis fort
longtemps je dis simplement qu'il y a
aussi dans notre paysage politique des
bêtes médiatiques politiques mais qui à
côté de ça font pas grand-chose de leur
vie politique et moi vous savez j'ai
aussi pour moi euh la réalisation de mes
actes et ça c'est extrêmement important
moi je sais que déjà je je pense que ce
parti je l'ai unifié et j'essaie de le
porter et au mieux mais par ailleurs en
dans mon engagement quotidien d'élu
local j'ai aussi des résultats et moi ça
me va aussi et je le dis très
franchement vous pensez quoi la
politique du logement la politique du
logement vous savez euh malheureusement
samedi dernier j'étais comme beaucoup de
personnes à l'hommage républicain qui a
été rendu au sénateur Claude Dylan qui
était l'ancien mère de clichis sousbois
j'ai travaillé avec lui pendant des
années pour sortir les copropriétés
dégradées de sa vie des difficultés on
commence à vraiment respirer un peu sur
ces coprés mais il nous faudra 15 ans et
moi à chaque fois que j'y vais car j'y
vais souvent voilà je me dis au moins
mon il leura été utile à ça au moins ma
fonction leura été utile à ça j'aurais
permis à quelques centaines de personnes
de vivre mieux plus dignement et c'est
ça aussi faire de la politique et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut aussi savoir
relativiser les choses moi je sais aussi
que j'ai ça pour moi et que beaucoup
d'écologistes totalement inconnus ont
dans leurs combats locaux dans leur
participation locale à des municipalités
aussi permis de faire vraiment changer
la vie dans leur territoire c'est un peu
différent aussi parfois quand on a la
tête d'une formation politique ù il faut
savoir se mettre en avant ce qui est pas
toujours facile oui et puis aussi une
volonté il y a ceux aussi qui aiment
apparaître comme les polémiqueurs comme
les petites phrases mais vous savez moi
je suis une des rares chef de parti qui
ne suis pas parlementaire et je l'assume
parfaitement conseillre régionale je
suis conseillère régional et je sais que
pour beaucoup c'est pas le bon niveau de
de de responsabilé vous fait sentir non
ah et je pense que c'est fini vous savez
la région Île-de-France c'est un budget
de 5 millions eur moi j'ai un budget qui
est plus important que beaucoup de
ministres alors vous savez je suis très
à l'aise avec les responsabilités et je
pense aussi que cette idée qu'il y
aurait les fonction haute et puis les
autres aujourd'hui en politique j'espère
qu'elle a un peu révolu ça va peut-être
bouger un peu avec la limitation du
cumul des mandats quelques question
d'actualité d'abord sur la fin de vie
avec le texte la proposition de loi qui
est examinée aujourd'hui par l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce qu'elle vous semble
suffisante pour combler les lacunes de
la loi
Leonetti malheureusement pas et c'est
notre grand regret nous avions nous des
déposé une proposition de loi qui a été
étudiée en en janvier dernier par
Véronique massonau notre député le
problème de la loi la léonique class
elle ne va absolument pas assez loin et
en plus j'avais eu cette initiative du
député Touren de déposer donc un
amendement avec 130 députés socialistes
pour aller plus loin sur la question de
l'euthanasie et donc que les malades
puissent choisir leur fin de vie je vois
ou je crois que ça ne va pas
malheureusement avancer vous ça ne vous
fait pas peur le
motanasie nous on a parlé du droit à
choisir parce qu'après derrière il y a
les question droit à la mort droit à la
mort de suicide assister pour moi ce qui
est essentiel c'est que les malades
puissent choisir et vous savez euh il y
a beaucoup de gens qui ne veulent pas
passer à l'acte ils veulent simplement
pouvoir maîtriser leur fin de vie comme
les femmes ont maîtrisé par exemple la
contraception et la question de de
l'avortement et moi qui a été une
militante de la lutte contre le sida moi
qui accompagné beaucoup de d'amis qui
sont morts du sida dans des conditions
très difficiles je peux vous dire que ce
débat chez des gens qui ont des maladies
graves il est ancien mais aujourd'hui
avec le viscement de la population
l'augmentation des cancers il est très
présent et notamment en janvier avec
Véronique massonau on avait été visité à
Gardane un établissement de FINB qui
s'appelle la maison pour discuter avec
des médecins qui sont pas spécialement
pour une évolution de la loi mais on a
on a justement discuté de nos
contradictions de comment légiférer
c'est un sujet très compliqué comment
mettre des mots législatifs sur la fin
de vie mais en même temps dire que la
loi suffit et même son amélioration
parce qu'il y a quelques avancées ça
suffira ce n'est pas vrai est-ce que le
combat c'est pas d'avoir plus de place
déjà en soins palliatif le combat c'est
d'avoir plus de lieux de soins palliatif
et des vrais soins palliatifs des des
endroits où vous pouvez déjà avoir des
soignants qui permettent de répondre à
votre douleur parce qu'elle est réelle
quand vous êtes en fin de vie mais aussi
qui vous amène des perspectives je oui
quand on est en fin de vie on peut aussi
avoir des perspectives qui se sur un
mois sur de mois et donc aussi avoir un
confort de vie parce que ce qui est
terrible aujourd'hui dans notre pays
c'est qu'on meurt très mal on meurt
souvent en souffrant pr on meurt à
l'hôpital avec un personnel qui n'est
pas formé pour ça et qui malheureusement
n'a pas non plus le temps et on manque
d'établissement et c'est sûr que ça
c'est le second débat que
malheureusement nous n'avons jamais y
compris mais estce que la solution c'est
d'accélérer les procédures parce que ça
ça revient à cela aussi on peut
effectivement mettre la priorité sur les
soins palliatifs renforcer services
c'est je pense qu'il y a deux débats
renforcer les services les créer
renforcer du personnel mettre des moyens
et donc ça veut dire aussi une dépense
publique qui est réelle mais qui
permettra aussi que les personne qui
décède le FE de manière digne mais c'est
aussi donner un choix aujourd'hui et je
vous le dis parce que j'étais un
colloque à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
quelques mois j'ai rencontré beaucoup de
personnes qui avaient objectivement plus
de 70 ans donc beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui en fait ont participé à
beaucoup des combats d'il y a 30 ou 40
ans et qui m'ont dit pour eux c'est
vraiment un choix ça veut pas dire
qu'ils l'utiliseront mais ils veulent
pouvoir un moment avoir la décision sur
leur mort et que ça ne dépende pas ni
d'un médecin ni d'un soignant en tout
cas est-ce que la fin de vie ce sera la
dernière réforme de société du quinquen
de François Hollande de ce quinquen là
écoutez je l'espère pas moi je je je je
continue d'être dans un regret très fort
sur la question du droit de vote des
étrangers euh je sais que peut-être qui
ne se fera sans doute pas sans doute pas
mais le problème c'est qu'on ne le sera
pas puisquon a jamais essayé et moi je
ne comprends pas que on mène pas des
batailles et notamment celle-là
malheureusement aujourd'hui certainement
que la MAJ de majorité oui mais on n
sait rien la réalité c'est que si on
avait vraiment réuni le congrès à
l'époque est-ce que vraiment nous
n'auons pas une majorité comment se
fait-il que des parlementaires centriste
qui donc un manque de François Hollande
vous dites je pense en tout cas que je
pense en tout cas que l'ensemble du
gouvernement héros n'a pas été assez
rapide et pour moi il aurait fallu
lancer cette réforme dès le début du
quinquen et avoir le débat on le doit
aux Français et l'ensemble des
politiques le doivent aux Français on
peut pas dire qu'on est pour à des
élections municipales pour aller
chercher un vote communautaire et à côté
dire à l'assemblée que c'est pas le cas
comme je l'ai vu au municipal che des
députés centristes très bien merci
Emmanuel C merci à vous vous en PR merci
merci perine et dans quelques jours
jeudi dans le cadre des émissions
consacrées aux élections départementales
il y aura un centriste justement sur ce
plateau HERV Morin merci à tous à très
vite